revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pared más debo con
nosotros nuevamente en el estudio rosa
para darle más exposición no para
desarrollar más el tema del que estamos
hablando uno de los más importantes del
día porque hoy se cumplen dos años de
esa explosión catastrófica que tuvo
lugar en el puerto de beirut vamos a
repasar la cronología rosa en esta
sección que ha marcado la crisis
económica política del país esto con un
interactivo especial llamado el whatsapp
de abandono publicado en the new
humanitaria en rosa vamos a empezar con
los personajes de tu esta historia y
vamos obviamente y él conversando sobre
el tema exactamente esta historia como
bien dices se basa en los mensajes
reales intercambiados por cinco personas
reales residentes en líbano y así se va
trazando una cronología que empieza un
año antes de esta explosión empieza en
agosto de 2019 y termina pues a día de
hoy no primero como vienen a comentabas
vamos a ver cuáles son rápidamente las
personas de las cuales vamos a ver estos
sean mensajes en un primer lugar tenemos
a afav de 30 años ella reside en trípoli
y es trabajadora social y dice que este
colapso de su país le ha hecho perder un
poco la fe en la humanidad porque mucha
mucha gente se ha aprovechado de la
situación económica para abusar de ella
por otro lugar mohamed de 26 años es
refugiado palestino se define como
activista y cineasta y reside en beirut
por otro lado tenemos a base de 26 años
que es periodista y que dice que el
colapso le ha hecho en cierto modo
integrarse en esta sociedad de la que
siempre se había sentido excluido
también está rossi de etiopía una
inmigrante que fue al líbano para enviar
dinero a su familia y por otro lado
roger de 39 años que es investigador y
también ayuda a refugiados sirios y
reside entre beirut y estambul bueno
rosa como empieza entonces toda esta
historia imagino que desde el año 2019
cuando pesó el debacle económico
efectivamente y empieza con una
conversación sobre la devaluación de la
lira en seguida pasa a octubre cuando se
producen los mayores incendios
registrados en el país hasta ese momento
y ya se empieza a generar una fuerte
crítica a la respuesta del gobierno dos
días más tardes de que se empiecen estos
incendios estallan las masivas protestas
contra el sistema político el libanés
pero que digamos el punto desencadenante
recordemos fue esa reforma política que
pretendía imponer un impuesto sobre los
servicios de whatsapp no y de aquí
también un poco este interactivo
publicado en the new y humanitaria el 29
de octubre límite el primer ministro
hasta el momento zachary y por ejemplo
para que veamos una conversación de
whatsapp una pregunta una amiga pregunta
a fav se puede sentir la adrenalina
mientras se duerme a lo que a rafael
responde cada noche sueño en que
participó en tres manifestaciones ocupó
cuatro edificios gubernamentales y
cuatro bancos no después el 21 1 de
enero de 2020 el nuevo primer ministro
hasan diab anuncia que ha formado
gobierno y un mes más tarde
aproximadamente se detecta el primer
caso de covite en el país y luego en
marzo el 9 de marzo de 2020
particularmente
y registra el primer incumplimiento del
pago de la deuda soberana en el país y
llegamos saltamos al 4 de agosto del año
2020 la explosión del puerto de luz a
partir de ese momento empezó a empeorar
todo en ese país rosa exactamente y
básicamente recordemos las cifras no
devastadoras de lo que causó este
incidente 200 personas murieron y 6 mil
500 resultaron heridas y como bien
comentábamos anteriormente las
investigaciones judiciales están
bloqueadas con una gran interferencia
política pero digamos que en el primer
momento los mensajes que vemos de
whatsapp que se envían estas cinco
personas hacen referencia sobre todo al
estado de sus familiares pero también a
las distintas especulaciones sobre las
causas que podrían haber provocado esta
explosión que finalmente pues ya se supo
que fue el nitrato de amonio almacenado
en el puerto no pero por ejemplo
fijémonos en este mensaje que manda
mirna una amiga de rouzier le pregunta
ya sabes lo que pasó o todavía no está
claro y él responde en ese mismo momento
las dos opciones posibles están en
momento serían que israel bombardeó algo
de hezbollah o que explotó un enorme
depósito de nitrato de amonio también
podemos ver pues los vídeos que se
envían no de ese momento que circularon
pues hay muchísimo por whatsapp y otras
redes sociales ante todo esto la caída
de gobierno efectivamente ya está y todo
su gobierno renunció y hariri que había
renunciado un año antes e intenta formar
gobierno de nuevo el 1 de junio ya del
año siguiente de 2021 el banco mundial
dice que la crisis económica y
financiera del líbano es la peor de la
historia en todo el mundo desde mediados
del siglo 19 el 15 de julio nueve meses
después de intentarlo por primera vez
hariri renuncia porque no ha conseguido
formar gobierno y el 26 de julio nayik
mikati es nombrado primer ministro
designado y en septiembre de ese mismo
año intenta y consigue ya finalmente
formar gobierno y para terminar
rápidamente todo esto en medio como bien
me comentabas de una crisis económica
que también va empeorando colas de
gasolina aumento del precio del plan
vemos conversaciones de por ejemplo afaf
que pregunta a su madre si le enseña a
amasar ya hornear el pan va si el que
pregunta dónde puede llegar al mercado
negro y finalmente ya este 18 de marzo
se publicó que el líbano supuestamente
es el segundo país menos feliz del mundo
por detrás de afganistán el 7 de abril
día el país llega a un acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional y el 15 de
mayo se celebran estas elecciones
legislativas y continúa la crisis
lamentablemente en este país rosa
muchísimas gracias por darnos entonces
un contexto digamos rápidamente desde
que comenzó la crisis hasta este punto
gracias rosa pasamos a saludar a nuestra
segunda mitad del día